what are your tattoos say I have two
Deepak Chopra quotes here he's like a
spiritual Guru of some sort this one I
got was my first tattoo when I was 18 it
says you alone are the judge of your
worth and your goal is to discover
infinite worth in yourself no matter
what anyone else thinks so for me it's
just something to wake up and look at
and just tell myself to be me he gets it
and I said huh is that bigger than you
wanted he was like yes it is
what is the arm you jerk off with
I'm right the meaningful arm yeah I like
that right yeah make sure Deepak Chopra
is involved with all that that's really
a good idea
I
[Applause]
that's the first time anyone's ever
brought that up
I might have to rethink oh my spirit
lives forever
I might have to rethink that
uh